girls can rub up on that micro dick and
some of them are like it's not so bad
I'm Josh Potter I'm here to answer the
internet would you rather a be
permanently hungover or B never be able
to drink again well I live a I'm just
constantly hungover I really am to the
point where I was like do I have
omnicrons but I don't because I I get
tested I'm like nope Josh you just drank
12 Beers yesterday like and you didn't
sleep and you got on an airplane yeah no
I live a so I guess I'm just gonna stick
with it because I'm never gonna I was on
antibiotics for two weeks and that was
like hell to not drink I was like I
gotta I would go to have a beer I'd be
like I can't so I'm going with a that's
like a too easy of an answer for me if
you could have one person narrate or do
play-by-play of you having sex who would
it be oh my God Rick generette 100 times
over yeah Buffalo Sabers 50th season go
listen to the music of Rick generat's
voice and tell me you don't want him
going School oh when you jizz I mean
that sound makes me jizz oh my God Rick
generat would you rather let your wife
[ __ ] you once with a strap on or take
her last name and get married oh my
goodness well this is like either way I
win this is like two good ones I don't
care about my last name to be quite
honest with you I really don't care I do
I take if it was a prominent woman too
could you imagine you're like I missed
your so-and-so I'm not beholden to my
last name I'm not Macho enough like that
like I'm also I don't think I'm ever
gonna have children to pass along my
name in here I'm gonna be a step dad to
begin with so I might as well take their
last name you know what I mean and then
to get to my wife to [ __ ] me with a
strap-on once like I think if my wife
and I are open-minded we might just try
that does it say that she sounds like
that that just sounds like a hey I'm
drunk let's see what happens here if you
came across a glory hole would you put
your dick in it no and here's why it's
always guys on the other end there's
never a girl there here's the thing
though you could if you just suspended
disbelief from mouth is a mouth and you
can just pretend but at some point point
no I wouldn't do it though I would just
it wouldn't it would it wouldn't be able
to escape my mind that it's probably a
dude there even if it was a girl you
know what I'm saying like it could you
could tell me all day long there's a
really pretty woman on the other side of
this and I wouldn't take your word for
it but I might put my dick in to be
polite if you had me at that point would
you rather have teeth where your hair is
or hair where your teeth are I mean I
have hair where my teeth are constantly
because I'm just shedding like a dog but
if I had teeth on my [ __ ] shoulders
that would be dope oh my God I'd be like
a rhinosaur or a dinosaur I said a
rhinocerer what the [ __ ] is that but I
would have [ __ ] I would run into
people I'd [ __ ] Jack people up UFC or
[ __ ] just in the street I could
murder hobos with my shoulders like oh I
just bumped into it
okay yeah what do I care I can mash up
my food with my arm hair and then just
suck it through a straw if I were in a
beauty pageant what would my talent be I
really don't think if I was beautiful
enough to be in a beauty pageant I would
scoff at the Talon challenge because I
don't think that they even should have
to do that if you're hot enough it
should actually be a lack of talent
challenge for a beauty pageant because
if you're hot enough you should not have
to lift a single finger or do anything
unique because you're that hot unless
the talent contest is like
who can eat and ask better or like blow
a dick or something that's like hack
though I would rather them to just be
talentless the talentless the more
beautiful I mean if I was pretty enough
I would just go in there and try and win
the judges over and yeah some way like
that I would just be like my talent is
I'm [ __ ] hot would you rather a sit
on a cake and eat a dick or sit on a
dick and eat a cake you know what's so
jarring it's not about sitting on the
dick it's eating the cake I do not like
sweets so that is like and the cake
seems like it would be nice to sit on
and I guess I'd have to eat I mean like
eating a dick I'd just get through it
but I would much prefer eating a dick
than eating a cake that is just my
cheeks are thinking about it the cake
that is not the dick would you have sex
with a dead person for five minutes if
you'd get your laundry done and folded
magically for the hell yeah oh my God I
think I've had sex with multiple dead
people their names are no I'm just
kidding um no but I don't do my laundry
or fold it ever I live out of a suitcase
so man give me that dead person where
are they let's go right now five minutes
that's it how dead do you want them I
mean five minutes is five minutes that's
I don't care if it's warm I don't care
if it's dust I'll [ __ ] a pile of dust to
get my [ __ ] laundry done and folded
magically would you rather live your
life as is or be a billionaire but you
have to blow dude every day give me the
dicks and give me the billions I don't
care every day yeah I just turned get
for a billion dollars I'd just be like
hey I'm gay now if that's what the
caveat was you know what I mean why who
cares you know it's fun right it's fun
these days
if you're gonna be gay ever now is the
best time right compared to I mean like
when was better never would you rather
bang a bunch of models but nobody knows
or not actually [ __ ] them but have
everyone think you did I think I'd
rather the second part because I kind of
live that as it is you know there's like
four porn stars that the internet thinks
I had sex with yeah and so and then
people are like did they [ __ ] and I'm
like I have to just spell it because it
gets a little too much and I'm like
we're just friends you know but it's
kind of fun for them to be like you
nailed that one like they think I did it
that's great that's great there's
there's one but there that's great I
like that that but if nobody knows like
there is one and I want people to know
but I can't ever say she would get so
mad and I'll never do it again
would you rather lose half your dick's
length or half your dick's girth this is
a double-edged sword for my deck I don't
want to lose either losing half an inch
on any sort of Dimension is rough but
here's the thing I've learned there are
some girls that have a fetish or maybe
not a fetish but know how to get off
with a micro penis and I don't have one
of those but I feel like it's you got to
go one way or the other I feel like
girls can rub up on that micro dick and
some of them are like it's not so bad
they pretend it's like a a nub or
something I don't know well I'm saying
I'd rather have like a like a [ __ ]
hockey puck yeah than just a short dick
okay because if I lose a length like
length it's very unimpressive I just got
out of you know where your dick's the
worst is a hospital I'd [ __ ] just got
out of an ER and boy oh boy you're
emasculated you're like a dog with a
cone on its head
I just have no deck yeah I don't want to
do that get one Bitcoin or debut for any
sports franchise you choose I'm taking
the second one because you can never
take that away from me I feel like
Bitcoin is going to evaporate and I
would debut for the Buffalo Bills and I
would just I don't even care if I don't
touch the field I would just be happy to
put on the uniform put on the helmet and
go do it Bitcoin is not even I don't
even know how to real money yet I'm just
learning and I'm just figuring that out
I'm scared of the metaverse too they're
going to start making real estate in the
metaverse and I'm just like getting a
lease in a in real life now so I'm
[ __ ] I don't want this Bitcoin [ __ ]
I'm going to lose all of it give me the
sports franchise cheese doodle fingers
forever what the [ __ ] is a cheese doodle
finger oh okay I'm not a snack guy now I
know what you're talking about on your
fingertips no I don't want this at all I
don't like that cheese doodle finger it
says the next one says or pay 1.5 times
things forever I feel like I do that on
accident as it is because I just I would
rather pay for convenience like I'd
rather look at a sandwich on a sign and
point to it and have some guy make it
for me as opposed to make it myself I
paid forty dollars for a turkey wrap
yesterday yeah 40. yeah dude like here
do it again too before I could cheese
doodle fingers [ __ ] off with that [ __ ]
when it gets wet it gets all shrively
[ __ ] off with that would you rather a
[ __ ] a down to [ __ ] six DTF for the
uneducated or B have 50 chance with a
nine give me the I'm a gambler baby yeah
yeah dude I want let's a 50 chance I go
I have a 50 chance with a nine let's see
where this goes how low does that have
to go for you to take the guaranteed six
I mean I'm still taking the guarantee
six when it presents itself sure but if
I had the choice yeah I know that's the
whole game
probably 20 actually 30 I'd still kind
of go like
one and three yeah let's give it a try
here one in three that's like my game I
feel like any time there's three girls
you go like one and three that's the
shot right there would you rather throw
up anytime someone says McDonald's or
wear a fedora for the rest of your life
and if anybody asks you about it you
have to say I like the way it looks yuck
give me the puke oh my God it is tough
though I know you're going to be walking
around and there's going to be
advertisements it's not when you see it
though right yeah so you could just walk
around going like
anytime you see that golden arch you
just plug your ears
you don't even have to hear it ever
wearing a fedora is tough you can't
escape that even if you're not walking
around going I like the way it looks you
might as well start talking that way if
you're wearing a fedora though that's
why everyone who wears a fedora is a jag
off because they're all in it they're
digging their heels in to whatever it is
that's going on that gave them the
Fedora and then they have to say dumb
[ __ ] like I like this if there was a
snail following you for the rest of your
life
and if you touched it you die how long
could you survive is it coming after me
it's impossible to quantify how long but
it would just be at the tail end of a
run I would sleep for like 48 hours and
that's when the Snail would make up its
ground or finally get me so however long
it takes the snail to get to me I don't
know where it's starting and where I'm
I'm on the road a lot I go I get to ride
in a plane doesn't know where I'm going
to be in the future well because here's
what I'm thinking like if it's just
following me wherever I go it's doing a
lot of zigzagging so I'm keeping it on
its [ __ ] toes so if I'm gonna take a
nap I would fly to New York to sleep for
like 24 hours and then I'd fly back to
LA the snail might make it to the county
line and then just be like [ __ ] and then
it has to come back and give me I think
I can maybe do that game for a while
yeah yeah I think as I fly enough it's
like keeping up your miles on like your
status on Delta I could be able to I
just would have to keep it up so the
Snail would start chasing me far away
and then have to come back and get me
wood would you rather have your mom send
you a nude or have her send all your
friends a nude I would rather my mom
send my friends a nude really all my
friends holy holy [ __ ] because I
that that's I mean I don't think that
they would jerk off to it you know what
I mean I think they would be like your
mom sent me a nude and it would be more
of like uh we're raising a red we're
raising a flag here we're intervening
hey by the way but yeah but I don't want
to see I would rather just know that my
friends saw it as opposed to me going
like in seeing the context of it like
what if there's words yeah when she
sends it where she's like I'm so wet or
some [ __ ] like that you're like no I let
them see it all my friends [ __ ] my
sister so really if they see my mom
naked it's just kind of like another
round of the course my sister blew all
my friends sucked all their D's she's
gonna love this so it's like if my mom
sent all my friends a nude they would
just it would just be the same you know
I still get fantasy football teams named
after my sister blowing people I know my
sister put her finger in my best
friend's butt all one time so I don't
care if I know that my mom sent my
friends a new
all right big thanks for watching ATI
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming Comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get them make sure you
subscribe to the channel right now